arthur lanternier bonjour bonjour
monsieur merci pour l'invitation merci
nous avoir rejoints sur la matinale de
rtl france alors on le disait alors que
le liban traverse une grave crise
économique politique sociale la
situation des chrétiens libanais
inquiète à tel point que le vatican
craint leur départ du pays alors
pourquoi absolument absolument alors
évidemment cette liste concerne toutes
les communes et les communautés au liban
mais en fait on a une grande peur de
voir la communauté chrétienne tout
simplement disparaître du liban ce
serait un drame entre le pays et
pourquoi les chrétiens en particulier
parce que ce sont souvent ceux qui ont
encore les moyens de partir aujourd'hui
on vit dans un pays où malheureusement
que ce soit les jeunes les moins jeunes
tout le monde
un seul message en tête c'est parti on
veut quitter le liban on veut quitter le
liban
c'est un drame évidemment comme en
faisant sortir lorsque sa population ne
rêve que d'une chose c'est de partir
mais en tout cas c'est le cas
particulièrement des chrétiens et elle
et chrétiens qui ont encore souvent un
peu de moyens pour pouvoir quitter le
liban sont en train de le faire moi-même
j'ai des amis j'ai des collègues et des
pleins de gens que j'ai pu rencontrer
qui décide de partir au canada en
australie en france en suède
partout sauf sauf au liban et ce qui est
dramatique en fait ce qui est dramatique
pour l'équilibré pour la bonne santé du
pays alors le président michel aoun et
lui-même chrétien avait vendu le sénat
comme un moment je le site de la
présidence forte et de la protection des
droits des chrétiens
pourquoi cela ne semble pas être le cas
aujourd'hui finalement et bien tout
simplement à cause de la crise est en
train de subir le pays je pense pas que
michel aoun soit le premier responsable
de la situation actuelle
la crise n'est pas en place depuis deux
ans fait de la crise n'a pas été créé
ces deux dernières années on est en
train de subir les choix politiques de
ces cinquante dernières années et ne
sera vous ne venez pas au pouvoir depuis
50 ans je pense que le président actuel
est en train de subir tout simplement
les choix politiques et économiques qui
ont été faits au liban pendant des
années il faut bien que les gens le
comprennent ça comment se fait-il que
pendant des années au liban on ait eu
encore des taux d'intérêt qui atteignait
entre 10 et 15% ce qui permettait aux
gens de rester à la maison et de vivre
uniquement avec les intérêts
comment se fait-il qu'on va nous guérir
dans un pays où tous les produits
subventionnés ont payé rien à l'essence
n'a jamais payé grand chose ici au liban
et plein de choix en fait économique
très hasardeuse qui aujourd'hui nous en
fait nous amène dans cette situation
catastrophique dont on essaye de s'en
sortir petit à petit mais
malheureusement comme vous avez expliqué
également on n'a pas de gouvernement
depuis dix mois pas de gouvernement
depuis 10 mois alors que le pays est en
train de traverser la pire crise de son
histoire et aux perspectives et aucune
perspective de gouvernement pour
l'instant langue pour l'instant dans ça
gesticule c'est discute on a
l'impression de d'actifs afin d'assister
un petit peu cour de récréation en fait
et nous on se dit mais là on est au
liban en train de mourir tous les jours
de plus en plus et nous avons des
dirigeants des représentants au pouvoir
qui en fait plus à leurs petits intérêts
encore personnel au lieu de s'occuper
enfin de l'intérêt du peuple qui est en
train de crever sans c'est en fait je
l'avais très bien expliqué de votre
portage il ya plus de médicaments il ya
plus d'essence il ya plus d'électricité
il ya plus d'eau je veux dire là dessus
du moyen-orient ou et m où est elle
c'est une catastrophe sans nom c'est la
pire catastrophe de l'histoire du liban
mois beaucoup de libanais 10 ont préféré
même la période pendant la guerre au
moins pendant la guerre il y avait de
l'essence il y avait l'argent qui
circule est aujourd'hui certes y'a pas
la guerre mais il n'y a plus rien on
peut plus vivre et on perd toute notre
dignité
c'est quelque chose de terrible en train
de vivre le liban est ce que sont en
train de diviser les libanais alors il
me suit la double explosion au port de
beyrouth c'était le 4 août dernier on
s'en souvient et il a détruit plusieurs
un des quartiers chrétiens historique de
la capitale
est-ce que là aussi ça a été un tournant
exactement exactement vous allez avoir
sciemment raison alors fait l'explosion
du 4 août est arrivé un petit peu comme
si je peux me permettre la cerise sur le
gâteau mais il manquait plus que ça
c'est vraiment entre la crise politique
la crise économique la crise sanitaire
il fallait en plus l'explosion du 4 août
qui s'est déroulé exactement comme vous
dites au coeur des quartiers chrétiens
de beyrouth
marie cry engine cgt ou gâcher tout ça
c'est des quartiers chrétiens
fondamentaux qui sont même des symboles
à chez afi et je vais pas me faire
l'histoire du quartier de la chefferie
et messer mais c'est quelque chose de
très fort et en fait ces quartiers-là
ont été meurtris au sein même de leur de
leur quartier au sein même de leur
maison et donc ça a été vraiment le le
désespoir le plus total donc en fait les
chrétiens de ces quartiers là en effet
le décide on va partir on va partir en
annonçant une caste politique ne nous
respectent pas qu'il ne nous respectent
plus on a plus d'opportunités
opportunités par d'autres
c'est surtout ça en fait les chrétiens
qui était réputé pour justement être des
chefs d'entreprise des entrepreneurs les
gens qui créent l'argent des gens qui
créent le travail dans le pays
s'ils partent tous devraient devenir le
liban alors les religions au liban sont
répartis en 18 confessions qui sont
reconnus par l'état représenté à
l'assemblée nationale grâce un système
de réservation de sièges principalement
musulmanes et chrétiennes
est-ce que cet équilibre propre au liban
aujourd'hui il pourrait être remise en
cause
je pense qu'ils pourraient être remis en
cause et devrait l'être je pense que si
on a un système communautariste mise en
place depuis le début c'était une des
sources des problèmes pas le seul
évidemment mais comment voulez vous
expliquer une population de ne plus
vivre selon l'appartenance communautaire
ne pas être divisés selon communauté
alors que le système politique lui même
et que nous ne tarissent le président
doit être maronite le premier ministre
un sunnite le président du parlement
doit être sheed une grand fête ce qui
amène à aucune cohésion nationale ce qui
amène à un choix politique à chacun en
fonction de l'intérêt de sa propre
communauté
au lieu de réfléchir à l'intérêt de la
nation en fait nous sommes avant tout
libanais où je suis avant tout chrétien
puis libérés ou avant tout un chip puis
libanais ou avant tout s'imite libanais
je pense que c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut savoir remettre en cause et enfin
essayer de créer un sentiment
d'appartenance nationale qui dépasserait
les appartenances communautaires
merci beaucoup arthur l'an dernier
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin je le rappelle vous êtes chef de
mission au liban pour sos chrétiens
d'orient merci